I loved all of you in this show I
thought you were all so unique there's
something so special about each sort of
demon in each sort of angel coming in
and getting to do their own thing
especially since this is an all new uh
season you know not based on a book or
anything so you're all coming in as new
characters except for for you Shelley
you're playing a different version of uh
balzebub but you know so if you're
coming into something new like this how
do you go about building the sort of
Personality for your characters well the
source material is a good place to start
with the with the you know the success
of the book and the first season there
was a lot to draw from there but then
the scripts that we were given are just
full and Rich and also allowed a lot of
scope for and encouragement from you
know from Neil and um our director to
doing you know embellish and and keep
creating to build upon what was given to
us and we also had a of help from
the the world that was created by way of
the sets and the production team and the
costumes and the hair and makeup and
that's even before you get on set and
get to work with your scene Partners
which is just you know the kind of
cherry on the top I think you know when
you have something that you know
sometimes it can feel a little bit you
know like you were saying this earlier
that you want to you really want to do
it justice because you know it's such an
incredible fan base and and the work
that has you know season one and and the
book it's just you know so rich but it
was like you know walking into set it
was such a relaxed atmosphere and it
really felt like a collaboration it
didn't feel like oh it's my first day at
school kind of thing you know like I'm a
little bit nervous and it was actually
just yeah this is our place of
collaboration and creativity and you
take what you need and you run with it
or you know it is everyone's just giving
you 100 all the time not just the actors
but you know the crew as well well so it
just was really smooth you know yeah it
didn't feel it didn't really feel like
like you said you know that we were the
newbies not really because everybody was
like as if you were returning again yeah
it's been there yeah which is great like
you were part of it so okay great I'm
part of it and to find your character I
think really so much obviously you can
watch the older you know the first
series and then the script has it kind
of all really does and then you just
you're saying about the uniqueness
you're you're allowed to just run with
it really and bring your own uniqueness
to it it was on along with the script so
that was that was the joy and I think
that helped probably is all get in there
yeah as new people on the in this chat
yeah yeah I can imagine that was the
case for you Shelly since you're coming
in sort of as the the second iteration
of of beyond the book were you given any
sort of guidance as to like does it need
to be similar to the first one or do
they kind of just like let you loose and
you know beelzebub's a demon you know
they're kind of unpredictable at best
yeah well I mean knowing that I would be
in the same outfit which fitted
amazingly
um as Anna Maxwell Martin who did a
phenomenal job I think of season one and
also talking to Neil and understanding
from him
um
how the character is it you know I mean
like he you know he I mean he just
solved it so simply by just kind of
going well this old phase I've had it
for centuries you know it's kind of like
it's just so simple and so it just had a
sort of flair to it that I think there
was the Simplicity of that that I felt
gave me license and
um
you know the character was well
established the fans loved the character
they love how they look so it was a kind
of step into with a kind of bringing on
board what was handed to me almost like
a sort of torch you know do continue do
you know what I mean and it was kind of
okay great so it felt like there was
some sense of the spirit that had come
from before still with me and like we've
said you know that kind of generosity
and collaborative Spirit of everybody
around you that's just kind of like yeah
come join in come join in and it just
sort of
it just means you can put your feet on
the ground and and get to work yeah yeah
and so we uh Liz inqueline you also Play
Angels we see a little bit more of
what's going on in heaven this season
given the whole mystery but we don't
exactly know what goes on in heaven we
see Muriel do a little bit of you know
investigative work uh like you know
examining a xerophone Crowley but Heaven
seems like an awful lot of admin so what
do you think they're doing when they're
not bothering a zero felon crawling you
know you said it admin
has been Muriel's existence and it's 24
7 but I also think they're happy to do
that you know what I mean that they're
just walking away yeah yeah don't don't
speak for something no no
um so
um yeah like there's a lot of admin
there's like records and records of
everything you know but so you should
you know they're just working away and
then the odd I don't know every few
thousand years that somebody will come
and be like oh I need to look but
miracle from so and so time and I'm like
yes I've got it right here right you
know what I mean so yeah that's you're
right it's admin it's admin it's all
right well I think spends their time
trying not to be bothered you know for
other people or not I think they sit in
their lovely corner office with a great
view over the universe and it's kind of
like don't bother me don't bother me you
know until you really have to and what
happens in season two is they really
have to because it comes out of the
office I have one final question for you
guys and that is the fact that uh one of
the big Staples of good Omens is
Crowley's Bentley which is cursed to
play Nothing But Queen songs forever and
ever and ever so I would like to know
what your favorite Queen song is oh
oh
um
oh yeah okay good there's just something
about that
uh it's Radio Gaga because I love the
sort of synchronicity of the arms uh
which is funny because I can't really do
it but I love it when you're doing it
and it was once playing in a show I was
doing backstage it was sort of the
coming on song so good memories but I do
love We Are the Champions as well that's
really like yeah yeah yeah I mean
there's not a bad one is there but the
one that just came to my head so I'm
just gonna call it my favorite for today
I might change my mind tomorrow is
another one bites the dust amazing very
good choices all of you thank you so
much for talking with me today thank you